[Musique]
virginie l'ensemble de mes collègues ici
présents au salon de big sister à toutes
les réunions
une annonce pleine d'émotion pour le
vice président du département
ce jour là la réunion rassemble tous les
acteurs du monde agricole à paris il
faut dire que ce salon international
impressionne par sa dimension
[Musique]
revenons au stand avec jérôme étudiant
en première année au lycée agricole de
saint paul comme ses camarades de promo
il est mobilisé sur l'événement en
premier regard très grand j'avais très
grand on se rend compte qu'en fin de
compte dans le domaine agricole ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
mettre en place et continue à mettre en
place au final
et on voit que l'agriculture peut encore
avancer car tous ces acteurs sont
présents un moment stratégique pour voir
demain collectivement un tournant de
l'agriculture on a une nouvelle chambre
on a des instituts qui surfe aux jambes
départementale aujourd'hui qu'il ya la
volonté faire en sorte que la culture
soit un pilier de l'économie
il faut profiter de la convergence en
fait découvrir les talents de
compétences pour que l'agriculture à la
réunion soit un pilier d'économie
rionnaise oui l'avesnois et tous sont
très beaux
au delà d'être président du conseil
d'administration de revient donc je suis
également président de la ligue de
diamant zurich et chaque fois qu'on voit
la réunion on se un rendez-vous qui est
devenu incontournable
une fille une véritable vitrine pour
toute la vie culture réunionnaise et le
conseil départemental avec toute cette
compétence agricole qui est la sienne
portent ces agriculteurs porte les
consommateurs portent l'agroalimentaire
ici jusqu'à paris c'est pour nous un
vrai challenge avait défi que nous
sommes en train de gagner une première
aussi pour le nouveau président de la
chambre d'agriculture
beaucoup d'émotion meurent montano que
d'accompagner ces agriculteurs qui sont
surtout des transformateurs qui viennent
proposer le meilleur de l'agriculture
réunionnaise ici à paris la chambre
d'agriculture va les accompagner pour
diversifier encore plus leur
exploitation pour que par exemple les
plus values soient captés par
l'agriculture et non plus que seulement
par des industriels
c'est à cet instant que la magie opère
le public se rassemblent les sentiments
remonte génial maison
et un couple typiques de là bas nous
avons la venue depuis petit aujourd'hui
moi justement métropole j'habite ici et
des foires c'est que du bonheur
[Musique]
les 23 exposants attendent maintenant le
public et en coulisses on prépare
l'avenir du monde agricole
notre avenir
en fait
[Musique]
à